If there are questions and answers we'll make
them available in a document linked on our
webinars page, which is where all of our courses
and webinars are, in the Materials.
The slides and the Q and A will be available
on our ftp site.
And that compressed URL will take you there.
So I'm going to turn this over to Evan.
Thank you Peter.
Hello everybody.
It is nice to see we have a nice audience
out there.
I am going to talk to you about PubChem, as
a source of laboratory chemical safety information.
If you are not aware what PubChem is as a
resource, I will give you a quick overview.
We're centered here at the National Center
for Biotechnology Information.
We contain the chemical content that is found
within the NCBI resource, called PubChem.
This is our home page, I encourage you to
explore it, especially the Services tab the
top.
That way you can have a greater familiarity
with the resource.
Our overall goal is to be open archive of
public information.
Our key mission has evolved slightly as a
function of time, what we aim to do is provide
biological role and function of chemical substances.
And health and safety is within that scope.
PubChem is a resource, content changes on
a daily basis.
If data is not there one day, you can check
back and it may be there the next.
The hope for this webinar is you will be able
to understand three primary things.
PubChem Compound is a source of information
for laboratory chemical safety data.
And the hope here is that you can understand
the LCSS, PubChem's Labortory Chemical Safety
Summary.
The source and content where you can access
the information.
But also how you can use and access it relative
to laboratory safety practices.
There is quite a number of reasons for this
webinar to be important for many people.
For one, there are three hazmat responses
to laboratories every week, academic research
laboratories account for about half of all
hazmat responses in the US.
And teaching labs account for 10%.
Education is the third highest hazmat response
sector.
Since 2010, the chemical safety board has
produced two major reports, on chemical safety
incidents in research and teaching laboratory
settings.
These are based on a classroom methanol fire
in 2006, and a serioes of research lab eventes
from 2008 to 2011.
There has been an ongoing series of laboratory
hazmat events since then.
It's accumulated a history of chemical accidents,
which have called into question the traditional
lab safety paradigm of don't make mistakes
and you won't have accidents.
And this led to more concern about the safety
culture of laboratories.
This has been addressed in reports by the
ACS and National Research Council.
Chemical health and safety data sources are
really blessed in many ways by having so many
data sources available.
This however presents an issue, in that there
can be gaps or errors in the information.
If all the information was available, will
decisions made by chemists change.
Every scientist you can think of, they may
not be aware of the various sources of information.
I have presented here a fraction of those
available.
Couple into this the fact that laboratory
chemical safety information is evolving.
There has been a recent transition from Material
Data Safety Sheets, the so-called MSDS, to
the global marmonization system, GHS, safety
data sheets, otherwise known as SDS.
This was a major step forward in part because
it provided a standardization of the information
content that would be available.
This has been further evolving through the
National research Council, put into practices
in the laboratory handling and management
of chemical hazards publication.
This was a step forward for laboratory chemical
users and described issues of scale related
to laboratory use of chemicals.
It provided a set of properties and a format
to be used.
The PubChem LCSS mirrored that content as
a subset of information that is available
within PubChem as a whole.
It includes various types of Hazzard safety
information such as flammability, toxicity,
exposure limits, symptoms and cleanup.
This evolution is important technically as
well as culturally, because chemists have
traditionally been disappointed by the limited
value of the MSDS.
You can imagine that with LCSS, this enables
all available health and safety information
or a subset of this and making it available
for ready use.
One of the reasons this is important relative
to PubChem is because it provides a wide breadth
of information and helps to move chemical
safety information resources from the limitations
of the 20th century paper media to leverage
21st-century chemical information technology.
We go one step further than the traditional
SDS that you might otherwise get via GHS,
by including other information such asspecific
reactivity information with other reagents.
So if you look at a typical property, such
as Boiling point, you can see who is providing
what information from various authoritative
resources.
A common hazmat rule is that three resources
have to agree on a property before an operational
decision should be made based on that property.
PubChem's collection of safety information
allows for a direct comparison of the authoritative
data sources.
You can access LCSS and PubChem from any page
that has this content, you will see a safety
summary link inside the page, that will give
you a laboratory chemical safety summary data
view for that same record.
But the content is reformatted in such a way
that is more in line in the GHS/SDS sheets,
but also to make for easy comparisons.
There is a fair bit of chemical safety data
content inside PubChem.
What you are looking at here is a data view
from the PubChem Classification browser, where
we're showing a classification tree for our
PubChem Compound table of contents.
Basically for the various information pieces
inside PubChem, you can see we have over 100,000
records with safety and hazard information
content, the numbers you see are the number
of chemical compound records inside PubCehem
that contain certain types of property or
property types.
For instance, for GHS classifications, there
are about 102,000 chemicals that have this
type of information content.
In addition you can see in contrast the stability
and reactivity information content is limited
to 5700 records.
Most coming through the national library of
medicine's hazardous substances databank HSDB
system.
In terms of global harmonization, you might
find that different data sources provide different
degrees of GHS classificaiton.
The nice thing here is that PubChem has provided
a subset of the GHS contents available.
Important to this, is the information content
that comes from the European chemical agency
through the reach efforts that they have in
Europe.
One thing you will notice is that PubChem
records will aggregate content.
So, if you see here for acetone, there are
78 different notifications provided by over
3500 different companies.
But you can see when you compare this information
content between the different sources, some
data sources such as that from the Japanese
NITE data source, this includes additional
GHS Hazzard codes that you will not find for
other records.
In part, being able to compare these different
data sources and then going back to the original
data source to find out why perhaps they have
selected these different Hazzard codes, you
can be provided more informed information
in terms of decisions.
However, there are some issues with the information
content that you can get through PubChem in
part because a chemical structure record could
have multiple forms of an entity associated
with it.
As we see here in the case of formaldehyde,
there are over 4000 companies providing different
notifications, and we aggregated this information
content, to let you know what percentage of
these notifications that are coming from these
company's are reporting various types of Hazzard
codes.
They may correspond to different forms of
the entity, that is of importance to your
use case or may not be.
You will have to examine and see what are
the different records and what types of information
content is available.
A main here is that PubChem opens up new options
for using safety data in a practical way,
by giving safety data a very customized form
via data streams.
You can download the entire content, go to
the PubChem FTP site, and download a zipped
compressed XML file, that has the entire content
of what PubChem knows relative to LCSS.
We update this on a daily basis.
We also provide extensive provenence information,
where you can explore data sources, and for
instance limit them to annotation sources.
So out of the 522 sources, there are 57 that
provide annotation content, you can examine
each individual record, for instance, for
the European chemicals agency, you can see
they provide us with various types of information
content such as GHS classification information,
and you can download that content in a datastream
that may be helpful and informative for your
purposes.
You can also download the information content
on-the-fly.
The earlier PubChem table of contents, also
lists the information sources, so that you
can see how many chemical records have information
from the data source.
In summary the PubChem laboratory chemical
safety summary contains basic information,
raw data, GHS ossification and more that are
important for you to make informed choices.
Or to locate information sources, to make
informed choices.
It's also an important piece of the ongoing
evolution of the laboratory chemical safety
information that helps you move away from
paper, and more towards simple way for you
as a human to read that content, compare the
content, and to work with it in a computer
readable way.
In part because it's downloadable in bulk.
And we have a breadth of data, over 100,000
chemicals, but also depth in the number of
entities which have other properties and information
content that is important.
It provides an extensive provenence trial
to allow you to understand which data sources
that are authoritative, and how we do the
data linking.
The work that you saw here today was not just
my work, from the various members of the PubChem
group, also in part due to our collaborators,
and a shout out to Leah McEwen, and Ralph
Stuart, also our software collaborators, including
NextMove, Daniel Lowe and others.
Also our PubChem contributors and collaborators.
This work was supported in part by the intramural
research program here at NIH, and I've included
several references for additional information
about what was presented today.
I will be happy to answer any questions at
this time.
Thank you Evan.
We do have one question in the question pod,
it says you mentioned LCSS is updated daily,
how rapidly does GHS information change for
a particular chemical?
In most cases the LCSS information is not
changing on the daily basis, however errors
that people make in the LCSS could be updated
at any time.
Having that update cycle, and also having
the inclusion of content on a regular basis,
allows us to keep up-to-date.
And other changes that are made within the
information enterprise.
As new information content is made available,
it gets added and we can access that additional
information content.
Okay we have another question.
In the aggregated data for example 73 sources
for the Hazzard codes, how do you delve into
the 73 that were aggregated, in other words,
how would you see those original reports?
So to rephrase what I heard in terms of the
question, can you access the original information
content that was used to make up the LCSS
inside of PubChem?
Yes you can go back to the original authoritative
information data source.
That content is available to you, in fact
when you start to see things that are different
between different authoritative sources, you
should immediately raise a red flag, to look
at what they are talking about in terms of
what aspect of that chemical.
Whether it could be a different phase of the
material, gas or a solid versus liquid or
mixture form of that in some cases.
Another question.
The evolution of the SDS, do you see LCSS
being a standard for chemical reporting through
suppliers?
I would say suppliers often have a legal responsibility
for the information that they provide.
While LCSS could become part of the data streams,
that you see from suppliers, that legal requirement
may provide degree of separation as to what
they want to report and why.
Is there a version tracking available?
Can we know what information was available
in December 2016 compared to today?
Not in the case of the annotations provided
to PubChem.
If it is in the archival part yes, however
annotations such as these are not archived.
You would have to go back to the original
data source to see what information was provided,
or to regularly download and compare the LCSS
content that is found within PubChem.
Okay here is one that will put you on the
spot, but I think it is a good idea if you
feel like doing it.
Can you do a demo to show them how to get
to this on the webpage?
Yes sure.
You can just type in PubChem , I will Google
in this case, go directly to PubChem, and
search for a record.
I don't know, what would be a good one?
Acetone?
A search within PubChem, it finds a number
of different data sources available, click
on the record and you can see the laboratory
chemical safety summary is right there.
You can click on it and access what you see
there, you have a download button, and you
can see the data used to display the page,
and download that in different formats.
You can learn how to get these to pull them
for a set of structures just by looking at
the url that you see there.
This is in Jason format, not for humans to
interpret but for computers, so if you have
a programmatic access route that you are interested
in, you have access to both.
If you want to go to PubChem , FTP site, you
can go to the Compound records, in the extras
folder, and access LCSS content directly right
here.
There is a classification tree inside PubChem
. You can go down to the Compound table contents,
and see the various information that is available
there, in fact you can take a query that you
had in this case we did acetone a moment ago,
I can pull that record in and it will do one
on-the-fly.
We can see the various keyword searches of
acetone, over 200,000 records but over 1400
of these have annotation content, of these
we can see there is safety and hazard information
for 223.
Moving around some of the elements on the
screen here.
We can figure out how many have GHS content.
I will turn off records that don't have any
information.
We can see various types of information that
is helpful and useful for our purposes.
We see 216 have LCSS data page.
We can look for stability and reactivity content.
If we are interested in those that have reactivities
and incompatibilities, you can click on that.
In this case we can see which records have
it.
We have ethanol methanol, various kinds of
records.
The neat thing that would be worth exploring,
you can expand the table contents, and find
other types of information.
Say you wanted to look at solubility, or reacitivities
and compatibilities, you can scroll to that
section.
I think I hit on a number of things that were
of interest.
I would be happy to entertain additional questions?
There is another question I don't know whether
I understand completely.
We noted when we download GHS from different
sources, the file is the same.
So EU regulations is the same as the NITE
CMC, and he lists something for one of the
PubChem URLs.
When you download information content by a
data source, you are downloading all data
for that datastream for all sources.
So you can filter that out dynamically, because
there is a computer accessible datastream.
The download at this point is not based on
data source.
We can make it that way, but it was designed
that way at this point of time.
Okay I think we need to wrap it up.
We are at time.
If there are any questions we didn't get to,
we will be able to address those in the questions
and answers document that's going to be posted
with the slides and everything else on the
FTP site.
Rememer that's going to be linked on the webinars
and courses page.
Thank you everybody for coming; talk to you
next time.